well I would see you I went to go visit
the superstore with the teachers yeah oh
my gosh it was so cute we were waiting
and we cut we were in the middle of
shooting and so they're like oh just go
over to the other stage and wait for
Kelly Clarkson to come and surprise all
these music teachers the cameras are on
us we're all ready to go we're waiting
and America just turns to me I had no
idea what was going on and she was like
are we supposed to pretend we're not
losing our minds that we're about to
meet Kelly Clarkson oh yeah she played
it off so well oh my god she played off
so well like I didn't I wouldn't have
even known she knew a song she owned oh
she's obsessed oh yeah yeah like legit
and literally you'd come in and she was
like hi the teacher to me like oh my
gosh you're cool so well towards the end
you said something about like you guys
should all come visit us on the show
sometime she I don't think you heard her
she went yeah you'll be friends
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that just blows my mind have you ever
just lost it when you met someone and
you were like wait that was not a cool
moment oh yes me so many times I think
the most memorable would be this was
this is my first movie role I ever
booked it was in a film called Lars and
the real girl starring Canada's
sweetheart Ryan Gosling I'm Canadian and
I was still living in Canada at the time
so it was like date it was day one of
the entire production it wasn't just my
first day because I had a smaller part
it's the first day of everything so
there's kind of a buzz around everybody
is I know it forgot all them all the
other smaller part actors we all know
each other we're like oh my gosh Ryan
Gosling like what's this gonna be and
then he shows up and he had gained a
bunch of weight for the role and had
grown this mustache that's the didn't
notebook died and so but but there's
like a hush around it's cuz it's Ryan
Gosling and nothing with everything
you're still like oh my god come on and
so we did we did a couple of rehearsals
and then we were being sent back to our
trailers as happens and I was walking in
front of a friend of mine a lady named
Aurora and I turned back as she was
talking me she's like oh my gosh even
with the weight even with the mustache
she's so hot but what she didn't know
was Ryan Gosling was right behind
and I wanted to be a good friend but I
also was like I can't show him that I'm
showing her so my way of handling this
was just speeding up fast can I get to a
door and I gonna push through the door
and I hit it
because it was a pull and so I smashed
into this door so hard and I turn around
to see Ryan Gosling in full costume full
getup method actor super serious just
laughing just out heard laughing at me
Oh Mike yeah that was a low embarrass
myself luckily every morning at 10 a.m.
in front of a whole nation is the
humiliation I've made a career I
embarrassed myself in front of Meryl
Streep in front of the nation yeah it
was I didn't know people were filming
and I didn't know she was gonna be there
and I yeah she's probably scared to me
no I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this